c'était encore avec nous un peu louis
dominé cette culture même si on change
de sujet on parle de musique toujours il
faut promouvoir la scène locale c'est
pas toujours évident et un site internet
qui s'occupe de ça mais oui un nouveau
site grâce à cyril à vermand des bons
soirs donc en effet vous avez créé un
site de d'écouté de musique en streaming
dédié aux artistes locaux mais alors
comment vous est venue cette idée alors
c'est venu de deux choses la première
c'est que je suis moi je suis je suis
membre de pas mal d'associations qui
organise des concerts pour les groupes
amateurs du coin pour promouvoir un prêt
cette scène locale et en discutant avec
des groupes je me suis aperçu qu'il y
avait un vrai besoin d'être diffusée de
mutualiser il me manquait un point de
repère et c'est aussi venue d'un gros
besoins personnels parce que j'en avais
marre d'avoir
dix onglets myspace de page youtube
trois pages facebook quand je voulais
écouter les groupes du point donc je me
suis dit il faut un site vous
centralisez tout ça pour pouvoir créer
des playlists et les partager sur
internet etc globalement quel est
l'objectif le concept de ce site alors
le concept c'est une plateforme de
streaming tout ce qu'il ya de plus
classique donc les groupes peuvent
s'inscrire eux mêmes gratuitement donc
ya pas de ses gratuits de ses
descriptions
et les visiteurs peuvent écouter la
musique
gratuitement aussi et de façon illimitée
il n'y a pas de quotas ou de règles ou
des extraits c'est à la musique est
accessible à tout le monde d'accord
alors on va regarder une paix un petit
extrait donc de présentation de ce site
internet
moi ce que je voulais à la base c'est
proposer une alternative aux grosses
plateformes de ce crime et qu'il existe
déjà pour vraiment centrale les gens sur
la musique locale les groupes proches de
chez eux
c'est important d'avoir une visibilité
aussi bien pour les amateurs que les
professionnels dont je trouve que le son
du coin ça va être un outil vraiment
l'air intéressant à développer en
partenariat avec les salles de concert
si on a envie de faire écouter son son
et le balancer comme un gros son de
reggae en fin de soirée et ton machin eh
ben on va sur la plate forme est bonne
on le balance et c'est facile et c'est
gratuit
alors donc ce site s'adresse aussi bien
donc quand des visiteurs qui veulent
donc écouter de la musique qu'à des
groupes qui veulent s'y inscrire mais
également je crois comme vous le résume
nié tout à l'heure aux programmateurs de
salles qui vont ici trouver l'ensemble
des groupes locaux qu'ils vont pouvoir
solliciter mais alors donc ça c'est ça
c'est à qui ça s'adresse mais quels sont
les avantages clairement pour chacun
d'eux alors bas les avantages pour les
visiteurs c'est que c'est que du coup
ils ont accès
tout tout tout ces groupes locaux
gratuitement ils ont accès à un agent
d'un concert aussi en hausse à l'eau
salée environ donc ils sont une bonne
visibilité sur la scène locale pour les
groupes ben c'est un moyen de diffuser
gratuitement
quand on n'a pas forcément les moyens
d'être dans une maison de disques ou
d'avoir un distributeur
et il ya une option aussi de
géolocalisation c'est une vraie nous une
vraie innovation
et après on fait qu'exploiter les
techniques existent déjà mais en bon
grâce à la géolocalisation
quelqu'un pour qui se connecte sur le
site pour avoir sa scène locale
directement sur la page d'accueil donc
si on se connecte à un côté
personnalisation de
ils les groupes de son de son quartier
les concerts de son quartier les celle
de son quartier d'accord alors
aujourd'hui si j'ai bien compris il n'y
a pas de publicité vous vivez de quoi
exactement alors pour l'instant il n'y a
pas de publicité parce que le site est
encore tout nouveau octobre à le
lancement ces lancements octobre 2012
donc à peine six mois
ça va venir malheureusement parce que
comme l'écouté gratuite avec le site a
un coût de fonctionnement évidemment ça
va venir après l'engagement que que moi
j'ai fait sur le son du coin c'est de la
publicité non intrusive donc pas de
publicité audio régulièrement entre les
morceaux pas de pas de pop up qui gâche
la vue donc très vigilants à ça c'est le
sait le moi c'est de vraiment
l'engagement que j'ai fait à la fois
pour les visiteurs et la fois pour les
groupes aussi qu'on peut forcément envie
de mevo espérer en vivre de ce site
internet alors on vivre ben moi j'ai
d'autres activités avec moi c'est long
mais ça sera voilà ça serait bien que je
puisse y consacrer la plupart de mon
temps et ça sert surtout bien que je
puisse rémunérer les artistes en
fonction des écoutes pour qu'ils
puissent développer leurs projets ces
artistes locaux on rappelle le site
internet sont du coin point fr et on
espère vous allez vous connecter pour en
savoir un peu plus sur tous les groupes
qui se produisent dans le secteur qui
sont originaires du département des
yvelines aurélia la jambe à une date
jacques fricker soit une date coup de
coeur ce soir en effet donc il s'agit du
concert de laurent madiot qui a lieu
donc au scarabée à la verrière vendredi
donc à 20h30 donc c'est un concert pour
présenter son dernier album de chansons
rock et glamour qui s'intitule en relief
prix d'entrée 8 euros et puis je voulais
se redonner la date les dates de
représentations du spectacle de notre
invité est dites éternelles edit éternel
donc ce sera samedi et dimanche donc le
13 et le 14 à la salle des fêtes de
bailly et donc on vous souhaite un
public nombreux merci beaucoup merci à
vous deux on poursuit cette édition du 7